because i do it's hamilton it's the
first ask ij of 2014.
so let's start with some questions from
all of you amazing people all right
first up princess shiv
what games are you looking forward to
the most this year i am super excited
for titanfall i actually i still have so
many games that i need to finish right
now on xbox one so when i finish those i
will be prepared and ready for a new one
corey wants to know i'm going to rtx
this summer rtx in austin is so fun i
absolutely love the rooster teeth
community i have never met more amazing
people ever by far the coolest so i
definitely hope that i will be able to
make it to rtx this year quincy what is
your favorite thing that you got for
christmas actually i just got my first
electric toothbrush so i'm pretty
excited about it my mom's like yeah you
can return it if you don't want i'm like
no mom i want this this is like a dream
come true it's something that i didn't
even know that i wanted and now my teeth
feel so freaking fresh crest is gonna be
calling and saying hi
this question really got me because i do
i've done this so many times if you drop
an ice cube on the floor do you pick it
up or do you kick it under the fridge no
of course you don't pick it up if you
drop an ice cube the first thing you do
is
kick it under the fridge if nintendo
made a smartphone similar to the 3ds
would you buy it i definitely would i
love nintendo i don't know how their
smartphone would be because i really
love my iphone but look i'm never
opposed to trying out some technology
you get crunk on new year's eve i i
didn't i sat at my computer edited
some sasquatch videos
and
cleaned my room unpacked from my travels
from the holidays
really
really boring and i really really
enjoyed it because the past couple of
years got a little crazy had a little
more fun than i should have ended up in
the hospital last year with jenna so let
me tell you what it was a really great
chill new year's and i liked it josh
wants to be posting more gaming videos
and yes i will i haven't really had time
to record any and when i'm at home it's
so hard to do it home as in my parents
house but now that i'm back here i'm
gonna be leaving again so i don't even
know it's i just need more time in the
day how was my christmas new year's
festivities i just talked about my new
years my christmas was great i spent it
at home with my family we had a great
time obviously we always have a great
time jack wants to know if i was
stranded on a deserted island
what three animals would i bring to keep
me company might bring three pigs i
would probably breed
them as much as i could so that i could
keep making more pigs even though i
don't really eat meat anymore i would
probably have to slaughter them and eat
them because i would starve otherwise so
i've got this planned out perfectly mike
wants to know what's influenced me to
start using my pc more than my mac don't
get me wrong i definitely still use my
mac a lot i use my pc so much more now
for video game capture because it's so
much easier to do on a pc than a mac so
that's uh that's really what has
influenced me also i love pc gaming
sometimes more than console so that's
that's it that's really all that has
influenced it nicole erica will you ever
do a collab with grace i
love grace i would love to she's like
probably one of my favorite people she's
so funny and just the things she says
like where did you come up with that
like i don't even know what the thought
process was of you getting to
point b from point a i mean you went
from you basically went from point a all
the way to like point freaking i don't
know
another letter in the alphabet i'm super
excited though because grace actually
started a new youtube channel it's
youtube.com it's grace no longer gonna
be uploading on daily grace anymore so
make sure you guys go check out her new
channel i'm so excited i can't wait for
all of her adventures and i'm not really
sure what to expect but that's the best
part about grace you never know what
you're gonna get uh andreas andres
andres what are my new year's
resolutions i first of all my first new
year's best solution was to not make a
resolution because
when anybody makes a resolution it's
like oh i have to do this i have to do
that and guess what yeah don't ever
stick to it so my resolution was to not
make one
i'm doing pretty good with it so far
uh flip kylie in one of my vlogs i said
i was gonna make a draw my life yeah no
i'm still gonna do it you wanna know
when uh i don't know when
if really honestly i promise you
here's my new year's resolution
i will make a draw my life this year
there it is that's my resolution and i
will do it so i have
360 some days depending upon when i post
this video
to
make it draw my life if you guys have
any questions for any future ask ig
episodes make sure you leave in the
comments below be sure to check out my
other youtube channels because if i'm
not posting here i'm probably posting on
one of those youtube.com
other ijustine i just needs iphone i
just in gaming so make sure you guys
check those out i will see you in my
next video and
that's it i hope you have a fabulous
freaking day i did know i was lost
thanks aloe black